during the pandemic crisis the
communication sector took an essential
role
especially during the period of
isolation and confinement that was
imposed
to the portuguese population our
networks and our technology have enabled
us to ensure
that the portuguese population could
continue to work to perform
their normal duties that our youngsters
could continue to do
their learning through remote education
and that we could take
remote health to everybody this besides
keeping of course the businesses
up and running this was only possible
due to the large investments that altis
portugal has made in the last few years
throughout the country an investment
made in the optical fiber deployment
but also on the 4g expansion this
private investment has allowed portugal
not only to cope positively with this
confinement period
but also to have one of the highest
penetration rates of optical fiber
through the population
and we were able to do all this to cope
with the challenges and the growing
demands of traffic
that we've seen throughout the pandemic
crisis and the confinement
because we have reached over 5.3 million
households in optical fiber
in the country and also around 99.5
coverage of 4g networks in our country
so
i would say that technology the
communications and and the optical fire
networks
have been decisive in this pandemic
crisis and they will for sure
be decisive for the future
you